some of my favorite games are ones with
immense amounts of replayability not
only is it cost effective but it also
sucks you into the game and its world
even more than it did before and it can
also give the player an opportunity to
discover things they didn't see on their
first playthrough but most of these
games are open world games red dead
redemption and the witcher to name a
couple but sometimes a game is created
that can break through that mold without
being an open world game
one of them being dishonored the
numerous articles and wiki sites
dishonored is considered a stealth
action adventure game not an open world
game
yet it feels like one at the same time
it's not an open world in the
traditional sense where after maybe an
hour or so of tutorials and prologue the
player is sent on their own to wander
the world and go as they please
dishonored sections the world off into
specific missions for example in
dishonored 2 mission 4
we're sent to find kirin jin dash owner
of the clockwork mansion from the moment
you enter you can already tell that this
gin dash fellow is clearly a wealthy man
this is in stark contrast to mission 2
where we can walk the streets of karnaka
which is filled with rundown and broken
houses oppressive gangs and infestations
the game restricts the player by not
allowing them to go from one area to
another but gives them enough freedom
within the missions themselves that it
feels like an open world adventure
and the game knows this as it mentions a
handful of ways you can accomplish an
obstacle in your path
letting the player know that there is
more options than you may think the
reason i bring this up is in reference
to the word in the title
duality dishonored whether it knows it
or not is the poster boy for this term
not just in its gameplay but in its
story and the latter is what i want to
focus on more today
dishonored's duality especially in its
story is aided by the game's unique
chaos mechanic
which is a mechanic that can change the
game based on the player's actions
the biggest influence of this mechanic
is murder the more npcs the player kills
the worse the game becomes
this can be small challenges like
different voice lines or in a much
larger consequence
getting the bad ending of the game while
not as identifiable as the previous
changes mentioned it can also show the
true colors of dishonored's world and
how separated the inhabitants of the
world truly
are to explain this more we need to
understand dishonored 1 and dishonored
2's story so from this point forward
there will be spoilers for both games
i understand dishonored is an older
series but considering that dishonored
is now on game pass thanks to the xbox
and beth has the deal i thought i would
let you know just a case if you haven't
played the game yet so dishonored 1
takes place in dunwall a city overridden
by a disastrous plague which has not
only caused catastrophic death counts
it's also ruined the economy and
separated the class system making the
power difference between the rich and
poor
even more immense we're still talking
about the game right we play as
corvo royal protector to the empress
until she was assassinated and we are
blamed for her death
eventually we end the game by crowning
the new empress emily caldwen who
becomes a playable character in
dishonored 2.
emily is now 15 years older and with the
rap play gone she can now relax until
someone claiming to be her aunt wants
her thrown back and forcibly removes her
and her subjects out of the castle the
red plague is gone but more problems
than just
rats await her in karanaka the main
location for the sequel both of these
games show the differences between those
in power and those who aren't in power
the biggest example is the rat plague
itself from an audiograph in-game we
discover that the royal spymaster the
main antagonist of the first game was
the creator of the plague he was trying
to find a way to end the poverty problem
in dunwall so he did this by attempting
to kill the poor
using infected rats from a neighboring
continent if a person is infected by the
rat plague symptoms can be as small as
discolored skin or
thinning of hair to its most extreme
which is loss of cognitive functions and
bleeding through the eyes because of the
lack of treatment at this stage in the
outbreak
most people who are infected are
sectioned off from the rest of the
population or just outright killed the
only treatment available is the elixirs
from piero and sokoloff which can help
reduce the symptoms of the plague
the issue is that they are in short
supply and expensive so only the guards
and the rich can afford them you know
the ones
not affected by the plague the reason
why preventative methods became more
extreme in game after we escaped the
prison is that the empress didn't want
to go through such methods but
chinchi's dead in the royal spymasters
in charge he authorized these additional
measures like the watchtowers walls of
light and arc pylons
all of which kill anyone who's not a
guard on sight which we can see a later
mission of a watchtower gunning
civilians down on the nearby bridge
there is also a mandatory dusk to dawn
curfew and anyone who doesn't comply
could also be killed
in most areas there are even large walls
that quarantine sections of the city off
from others preventing people from
either going back to their homes or
trying to leave their homes all in an
effort to stop the spread
it's clear that instead of trying to
cure the population they are waiting for
the plague to kill the poor
while the rest resume their daily
activities all this has been attributed
to dunwall's government and upper class
being more oppressive and obtrusive to
the rest of the population
throughout the area of the game the
player will end up finding signs symbols
and
corpses everywhere there are signs
asking the already suffering residents
to make sacrifices to help better the
rest of the population
there's for sale signs on people's
apartments in hopes they can get money
to afford the elixir of course at the
cost of selling their only home and just
piles of corpses as we could see guards
being instructed to throw dead residents
off a bridge
this is just a simple introduction to
the game's duality but i can't think of
a better showcase of class division
within dishonored 1 than the boyle
mansion and the flood district
in mission 5 we as corvo need to get rid
of lady boyle who is the mistress and
financier to the royal spymaster meaning
she's funding the technologies that are
killing off the population
and separating the rich from the poor
conveniently she's throwing her annual
masquerade party at the mansion so we
can blend in with the guests using our
newly acquired mask
we arrive near a small dock and are
given the whole level to explore
near the mansion is a closed off gate so
that only the party members can attend
it's unclear how the guests who made it
to the party as were the last ones to
arrive but they most likely came by a
railcar as many are seen throughout the
mansion something only the rich have
access to guarding these gates are still
walkers called tall boys purposely made
to keep the guard piloting it out of
reach of weepers and infected rats
they patrol the gates in nearby streets
and will just like everything else in
the guard's arsenal
kill all infected or trespassers on site
on a loudspeaker before we enter we can
hear that by request of the local
landowners that being the boils the
streets are off limits and that any
unauthorized intruders will be dealt
with
this shows that simply by asking the
rich can get what they want
as stated before our mission is to sneak
into the mansion but if we detour away
from the main objective we can go across
the street into the rundown sections of
the district
all the buildings on the outside are
policed by nearby guards equipped with
various floodlights and weaponry to
block off intruders
inside isn't much better as it's covered
with abandoned rooms bloodstains and
graffiti all over the walls
messages written in paint or scratched
on doorways are a common sight
throughout these areas such as death
threats insults and overall just creepy
notes
as for the residents they are either
dead or infected with quite a few
walking the halls of the building
this is already bad enough but just
across the street are the boyle's
mansion
filled with bright lights fireworks and
beautiful architecture it's a complete
slap to the face to any of the residents
residents who aren't rich enough to
afford food to eat and elixir to help
cure the affliction
whereas the boils have more than enough
food for everyone and don't need to
worry about the plague
the outside of the mansion is lined with
streamers rich guests a plethora of
lamps
lavish gardens of flowers and music to
accompany the guests
they of course have the protection of
the local guards so they don't need to
worry about any unwanted guests or rats
sneaking in
and since the party is inside this time
around that means more recreational
activities are dealt with
outside like fencing or dueling all the
guests are dressed in expensive suits
and large over-the-top
masks which fit the theme of the
masquerade party according to some notes
we find out that the sisters also hire
seamstresses and tailors for each guest
that is invited so they have the perfect
outfit for the party
inside is even better looking as soon as
we enter we're greeted with a large
ballroom with shiny white walls
outlining the building
confetti raining from the ceiling and
ornate furnishings connecting each room
is more of the aforementioned design
structures and party favors there's also
a library full of books that could take
years to finish in a small room that
doubles as a relaxing place for guests
to sit and eat as well as showing off
the numerous trophies that they have did
i also forget to mention that this was
only the first floor as upstairs is
where the boyle sisters sleep i should
probably explain by now that the boils
are triplets which is the main point of
the mission we have to find out which
one is our correct target
but this shows that it's not just one
sister's wealth being poured into the
party it's all three of theirs
all the sisters have their own rooms and
wings that include things like paintings
aging pieces of art separate bathrooms
and much more
they clearly live a lavish lifestyle and
don't mind letting others know
considering the vast amount of wealth
they use just to host the party
the boyle's mansion is the epitome of
showing off flaunting their wealth to
the poor who are so desperately trying
to survive while the rich and wealthy
ignore the issues outside the walls and
enjoy a relaxing evening
the other side of the colon would be the
flooded district of dunwall
playable during mission 7 the flooded
district was flooded due to the nearby
dam breaking and causing all the water
from the river to steamroll the
district's infrastructure most of it is
occupied by the whalers a gang led by
the assassin dowd but some of the areas
are in control by the local guard this
whole district is an issue in itself not
only are the people's homes destroyed
leaving them to just wander the streets
or
what's left of them there's dowd's gangs
betraying the rooftops and the whole
place was sectioned off by the rest of
dunwall this is because instead of
fixing the district the government under
the royal spymaster's rule turned it
into a mass grave when we finally escape
the majority of the flooded areas we
walk past some rubble to see a rail car
dumping dozens of bodies out of it right
on top of where we're walking
this place is practically a trashy
internment camp all the city's garbage
from traditional trash
whale bones and corpses go in here
there's also quite a lot of infected
people here too
as anyone who agrees to the royal
spymaster's rehabilitation program
whether they've volunteered or not
is send here to be quarantined away from
everyone the disease is going to kill
them anyway so why waste the whale oil
to drive their corpses over to the
district when you could just put them in
the district to begin with
it's like digging your own grave except
this time it's already dug the moment
you're dragged in here of course the
district is surrounded by large arc
pylons walls of light and other
machinery to prevent people from
escaping
they are forcing the people to stay in
the district and give them no option to
leave
like i said you're dead the moment you
walk in and that rail car comes quite
frequently you could say this is done on
purpose as this is a way to escape the
district so it's more of a gameplay
mechanic but if we were to shut that out
of our minds for a moment
it's insane how fast this comes back
with the number of bodies it has
every couple of minutes or so it comes
by and pours dozens of corpses into the
district letting them rot and it keeps
coming back with more and more bodies
i did do a bit of research for this on
the wikipedias i couldn't find any info
in game but apparently dunwall had a
population of around 2 million before
the plague and
currently in-game is around 200 000
people left so just think about that for
a moment there are tons of areas like
this
in fact all areas are very much the same
with having run down buildings
patrolling guards and dead bodies along
the streets
but i want to dial it back to the chaos
discussion as i said earlier the chaos
level determines the ending of the game
and while it also changes the ending
mission
the after credit narration is what i
want to focus on more should the player
kill little to no one in their
playthrough they'll get the low chaos
ending which he's emily become empress
with the rest of the residents clearly
having happier spirits
because we decided to not act out and
kill others piero and sulkeloff can be
seen combining their separate formulas
into a new elixir that can cure the
plague which as the outsider states
brings up a golden age of dunwall where
the plague eventually becomes eradicated
alternatively if we kill lots of people
throughout our playthrough we received
the high chaos ending which shows emily
becoming the empress except no one is
happy and can be seen arguing at one
another as one even attempts to harm
lady emily there are also scenes of
corruption and gang violence as some
members can be seen looting
corpses the red plague isn't even close
to being dealt with if anything it's
grown thanks to the vast amount of
corpses we left behind harboring the
disease
this is clearly not a great ending and
thankfully the canon option for
dishonored 2
is the low chaos one and speaking of
that let's transition to dishonored
sequel as the duality between the rich
and poor and karnaka is arguably just as
bad if not worse even with the lack of a
citywide plague
dishonored 2 as stated before is 15
years in the future the rat plague is
gone and things are going smoothly with
emily being the current empress that is
until her supposed aunt delilah claims
she is the rightful heir and throws us
out the game then gives us the option to
play as corvo again or
emily personally i've always thought
emily was the canon choice so i chose
her for both playthroughs and that's how
i'll be referencing certain parts in the
video with her as the main character
the chaos system also makes a return in
dishonored 2 but there's no plague so
what changes well karnaka has a bit of a
blood fly infestation these are native
insects to karnaka and they will make
their nests in abandoned homes and dead
bodies so the more bodies we create the
more blood flies
as deadly as they are when the insect
becomes an adult they lose their wings
and are considered beetles which the
residents of karnaka use for their crops
sometimes bugs do get in people's houses
which is not uncommon but the vast
amount of nests we see in the game is
totally unnatural when the infestation
was at its worst the duke of sirconos
luca abell provided a very detailed
guide on what to do to prevent more
blood flies like cooperation with the
guards instructions on cremation
and other preventative measures but
eventually he stopped funding the
project which caused the bloodfly
infestation to skyrocket and now the
only people able to exterminate them
are brave civilians possibly wanting to
do some quick coin
as the amber inside the nests are quite
valuable but considering they don't have
the weaponry the local guard carries
most of these people end up dying
which once again leads more blood flies
creating a never-ending cycle there's
also a disease that these blood flies
carry too
not every nest these flies make are dead
bodies some
are considered alive the blood flies lay
their eggs in the body of a person
this also causes their cognitive
functions to cease where the only thing
on their mind is ensuring the safety of
the nest
if they're killed a swarm of flies will
erupt from them making it even more of a
hassle to deal with i wanted to explain
the danger these insects pose to the
citizens of karnaka now as i'll be using
them to make a point in the future
arcane studios also did a really good
job of hiding these issues from the
player before we set foot there
after the first hour or so of missions
we and megan foster set out to karnaka
for the first time
and it was breathtaking the city is
coined as the jewel at the edge of the
world and it's truly a beautiful city
railways going across the ocean large
towers and trees
windmills on every corner and not to
mention the giant mountain in the
background which is such a magnificent
sight but it's all because we're on the
outside looking in from the moment we
step on the dock it loses that beauty as
we turn left we see blood in the water
coming from the sewer system they stock
in most likely a large part
of the port is dedicated to whale
hunting most of the good equipment seems
to be out of reach of the regular
population so some have taken to selling
it under the table so to speak is this a
variety of black market shops that can
sell us elixir upgrades and other
equipment and nearby we can also see our
first introduction to the blood fly
infestation
outside is three people arguing about
the plan they seem to be very indecisive
about going in
as they're unsure if there's even any
money inside the house and if the risk
is worth the reward we can also see that
once the flies move in the house is
totally inhabitable not only are the
flies an issue because of the risk of
being stung and becoming a host there's
also a wax-like material that is molded
together to hold up these nests which
makes it even harder for the nest to be
cleaned out i wouldn't be surprised if
many people could never return back to
their homes even if the nests were gone
as the additional material covers up
more surface area than the actual hive
itself
this then leads us to dr hypatia she's
one of our targets in game but she's
also working on curing the blood fly
fever that numerous residents have
experienced which is great
except the duke is to blame for keeping
her trapped at the institute in fact i'd
go as far to say the duke is the cause
for everything happening in karnaka
the previous duke was thedonia sabelle
he was very well respected amongst
everyone in karnaka the gangs like the
abbey and the howlers as well as the
regular citizens both rich and poor
when the donis died he passed the power
to his son luke abell the current duke
his ruling of circonus but more
specifically karnaka is quite the
opposite of his father
luke despises the abbey and he uses his
power to oppress the people of sirconos
using his authority to shut down any
rebellions that may spark up kinda
sounds like someone else we just talked
about luke's father was also friends
with aramis stilton who is the owner of
the mines here in karnaka but thanks to
his eventual insanity he would give up
control of the minds of the duke who
while doubling the profits of the mines
more than likely made the conditions
worse for the workers in the process
this is also the cause for the constant
dust storms we see in the dust district
his reasoning for overworking the miners
was so that he could afford his lavish
lifestyle this not only caused more
people to be sick because of the
conditions of the mines but also be
exhausted and collapse while working to
make matters worse the howlers a local
gang
wanted more territory and attempted to
set up in the dust district this is at
the same time the abbey wanted the
territory for their own to build a
chapel with the guards being overrun by
two gangs they pulled out of the
district and put up security checkpoints
with
walls of light surrounding the district
so nobody could escape that means that
anyone that just happened to live in the
district with no affiliation of the
gangs now has to suffer the consequences
going back to that statement about his
lavish lifestyle we had an up close look
at his mansion in mission 8 where we
attempt to assassinate the duke
according to emily the grand palace
costs enough money to feed the people of
karnaka for years so instead of
supplying more food for those in need he
decided to make a lavish mansion instead
and within seconds you can already tell
just by looking that the palace is made
of way different material than the
houses in the other districts
more rooms than you can count including
separate rooms for his bed and work
quarters
a library a vault that hides delilah's
soul but also doubles as another library
and floors upon floors of different
rooms for the guests and other
activities and best of all
no blood flies the reason i bring this
up about the duke is i'd like to argue
that the duke is just as bad if not
worse than the royal spymaster to an
extent the rat plague affected both the
rich and poor
we can see in the boyle mansion the
occasional rats sneak inside it's
obvious that the poor were affected more
than the rich aristocrats but it
affected them albeit very small we could
see some aristocrats argued during the
party about their businesses
one saying that he won't make as much
due to most of his land being covered in
corpses and rats
so it's clear that some rich are
affected by the plague but the blood
flies the dust mines and the poverty
problem
only affect the poor in karnaka most of
karnaka's districts are overrun with
local gangs and people in poverty
living in run-down buildings with
chipped walls broken stairs and graffiti
on every wall
some aren't even able to live in
buildings thanks to the blood flies the
miners themselves are overworked and
exhausted some
dying from exhaustion while those who
survive are being poisoned from the
terrible air quality inside the mines
in the other districts is where most of
the blood fly infestations are and while
there was a plan to eradicate them the
duke stopped funding the program which
caused more people to die
more houses to be lost and more blood
flies to be born causing a never-ending
cycle the only person who was willing to
help was dr hypatia who was working to
solve both issues but she was placed at
the institute
and trapped her under the duke's rule
only letting her out when he wanted to
this was all happening while the duke
was according to megan
living a relaxing life sipping wine and
having daily orgies and anyone who
attempted to stop him was immediately
put down by the guards
so i leave the question to you who given
the circumstances of each city and
nation
is the worst the royal spymaster the
creator of the plague on an attempt to
solve the poverty problem of dunwall
only to have it spread too quickly
causing mass genocide and sending those
who are infected to their deaths or the
duke a tyrannical ruler who kills anyone
who disagrees with him refusing to fix
the infestation and instead overworks
the miners till they collapse so he can
fund his rich palace
this is what i mean by the duality of
dishonored both games showcase the
insane amount of power the rich have
over the poor and it only gets bigger as
the days go on
letting the rich continue to enjoy their
life in the city while the poor fend for
themselves without any assistance from
the government
that government being the one who caused
the problems in the first place
all right i think i've talked enough for
one video so we're going to be moving on
to the outro portion of the video which
means that can be a little bit more
informal with my wording thank you all
for watching today's video
let me know what you think about it in
the comments down below also like i
brought up before with the recent deal
between bethesda and xbox dishonored is
now on game pass so this is perfect
timing for those who are new to the
series it's one of my all-time favorites
like always subscribe if you're new for
more narrative commentaries like this
one on all your favorite games and if
you're a returning viewer i thank you
for coming back
if you want to watch another video of
mine i highly recommend my previous
upload which
talked about far cry and why the
villains are so well written within the
series
with that take care everyone hopefully
i'll see you in another video in the
future
and goodbye
[Music]
you